Hello.
My name is Bruno Oliveira, and I
work in the Play Games team.
Today, we're here to talk
about two of my favorite
things, which are the Play Games
API and the NDK, and how
to use those two
to make a game.
So when you're writing a game
using the Play Games API, you
normally have to worry about
connecting all of these
callbacks that the Android
life cycle gives you.
So we have onCreate, we have
onStart, we have onStop,
onActivityResult, and several
other callbacks.
Normally if you're writing a
game that's not native, you
can usually get away with just
subclassing BaseGameActivity,
which is a class that we
have in the samples.
When you subclass
BaseGameActivity, all that
life cycle is connected
for you.
Now of course, if you're writing
a native game, as you
know, you can't subclass
BaseGameActivity.
Why?
Because you have to
use NativeActivity
for a native game.
So we're going to talk about how
to set up NativeActivity
to do exactly that.
So first of all, you
don't have to use
NativeActivity as it is.
You can actually subclass it.
So this is what we do here.
So before anything, we start
with actually NativeActivity,
and then we derive our activity
class from it.
So in this case, our game is
called "Awesome Game." So we
are deriving AwesomeGameActivity
from
NativeActivity.
Since we're going to use
the GameHelper--
which is also in the samples--
we also implement
GameHelper.GameHelperListener,
which is the listener class
that GameHelper uses.
So next, we declare GameHelper,
inside of our activity.
And we're going to have to
manage its life cycle.
Remember, this is actually done
by BaseGameActivity, But
it's not actually very hard
to do it yourself.
To do this, all you have to do--
first of all, you want to
load your game library, because
it's an NDK game.
So we're loading the
game library, using
System.loadLibrary.
Next we want to hook
up the GameHelper.
To do this, for example, when
you have onCreate, so first of
all, you create your
GameHelper here.
And then what you have to do
is call GameHelper, like
mHelper.setup.
And this is when you do the
setup for the GameHelper.
Here, we're specifying that we
want the GAMES client and we
also want the APPSTATE client.
And we're going to use
those in our game.
After you do onCreate,
all you have to do is
do the same on onStart.
So whenever you get the
onStart callback, the
GameHelper needs to know that
the onStart has happened, so
this is how you hook it up.
On onStop, it's been pretty
much the same thing.
So on onStop, you just call
mHelper.onStop, and that
connects it correctly.
Next, you'll also to
onActivityResult.
You'll do just the same thing.
You're just calling helper to
notify that, that the result
has come in.
Because that's necessary for the
whole sign-in process with
the dialogues and so on.
So you need to get the results
to the helper.
Next, you have to wait for
the sign-in callback.
So you're going to be notified
that sign-in succeeded or
failed through the sign-in
callbacks, like
onSignInSucceeded and
onSignInFailed.
So that's when you probably
want to notify your native
code that the sign-in has
succeeded or failed.
So let's talk about how to
actually do sign-in.
So first of all, we're not
going to talk into great
length about the JNI.
But you have to initialize
the JNI.
So first of all, you
can do that using
AttachCurrentThread, and then
have a working attachment to
the thread that you can
use to make JNI calls.
Of course, don't forget--
because
that I made that mistake--
don't forget to detach
the current thread.
Otherwise, we're going to get
strange crashes in the
background.
After you're done setting up the
JNI, you're probably going
to want to have a sign-in button
somewhere in your game.
So the sign-in button pretty
much looks like that.
You have some liberty
to customize it.
But when the player clicks on
it, you should start the
sign-in flow.
So the sign-in flow is the whole
set of dialogs that the
player has to click through to
actually authorize your game
to access the Play Games API.
So when the user clicks that,
what you want to call--
this is in Java, of course--
you want to call
mHelper.beginUserIntiatedSignIn.
So that's going to begin
the whole sign-in flow.
However, since are going to be
calling it from the game
thread- so remember, that the
game is going to be running on
a separate thread.
It's not the UI thread.
So you need to wrap that with
a runOnUIThread call so that
you can actually call that
method from the game thread
and have it execute
on the UI thread.
So this is why we have this
method, which is called
postStartSignIn, which
essentially can be called from
any thread and post
to the UI thread.
And there, we call
mHelper.beginUse
rInitiatedSignIn.
Now, let's show how
to actually start
the flow from C++.
So nobody's afraid
of JNI, right?
So this is how we invoke
that method using JNI.
It's just standard JNI.
Just get the activity object,
the activity class, and then
we get the method ID for our
method and then invoke it.
Notice that when we do this,
we actually sidestep one of
the major difficulties of using
JNI in Android, which is
that if you just try to find a
class by name, it's not going
to find it because it can only
find the actual framework
classes using FindClass, unless
you do funny stuff with
class loaders.
So notice that we are completely
sidestepping this
whole difficulty by just
using our own activity
as a starting point.
So we're using our own activity
and calling method
that we wrote.
After we call this, then we
get the sign-in flow.
All right, so after we do the
sign-in flow, you have to know
when you're actually signed in
so that your game can respond
to that appropriately.
You're going to know that when
on the Java side, you get this
onSignInSucceeded callback.
So that's the callback that
tells you that sign-in has
succeeded, or else that the
sign-in has failed.
So how do you actually
notify the code?
Well, you can--
to notify the native code
that this has happened.
What you're usually going to
have to do is to write the
native method that the Java side
can call and then notify
your native code that
this happened.
One of the ways to do this--
actually, I think it's a pretty
useful pattern-- is not
to have just a Boolean
saying yes or no.
It's actually to have a
three-state variable, saying
either sign-in has failed,
sign-in has succeeded, or
sign-in is in progress.
And then from native code, you
can react appropriately to
those states.
So we're declaring these states
as constants here.
And then we're also the
declaring a native method from
Java, which is report
sign-in results.
And we're going to call that
method whenever we want to
report a sign-in result or
progress to native code.
So this is how we do it.
So when we are on onStart,
we say that
sign-in is in progress.
Why?
Because every time your
application gets an onStart,
like comes back from the
background or anything like
that, sign-in is
not ready yet.
So sign-in is in progress,
because Play
Games API has to reconnect.
It's only when you get
onSignInSucceeded after
onStart that you can actually
start to make calls.
So whenever you get onStart,
this is when you report to
native code that the sign-in
is currently in progress.
Then, of course, when you get
onStop it's the same thing.
You also say that sign-in is
in progress, even though it
had succeeded before.
Why?
Because when you get onStop,
sign-in is no longer working,
and it's in progress because
it's going to come back later.
Then when we onSignIn--
actually, when you start the
sign-in process using
postStartSignIn, which is the
method that we just showed,
you also say that it's in
progress because, well, the UI
flow is happening right now.
And at the end of it, you're
going to get on sign-in
succeeded or failed.
Next, of course, when you get
onSignInSucceeded, that's when
you report that the sign-in
state is success.
When you get onSignInFailed,
you report that
sign-in was a failure.
And then your native code is
going to have to know how to
handle those states.
So next, how do you actually
handle this from native code?
It's just a JNI native method.
So all you have to do is write
that method signature, that
you can generate with Java H.
And then when that method gets
called, all you have to do is
react to that.
One caveat is that you're going
to be running on the UI
thread on that method.
So be careful not to try to
manipulate your game state and
so on in a way that may clash
with your game thread.
So usually, one of the useful
methods there is just to use
some sort of synchronization,
or write to a write-once
variable, or something
like that.
But it's important to note is
that it's going to be on the
UI thread, so don't do
anything funny there.
All right, so that's pretty
much all there is for this
first episode.
Please watch the other ones,
Because then we're going to go
more in depth into
achievements.
Leaderboards, and to how we
can actually do this on a
deeper level.
Thank you very much.